[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es auf einem
kanal eine leckere und hübsche kinder
pinguine torte
das besondere an dieser leckeren torte
ist dass sie im anschnitt aussieht wie
ein kinder pinguin die torte besteht
nämlich neben einer leckeren sahne
mascarpone creme auch aus einem leckeren
schoko boden und einer schicht
schokolade für den schoko boden
benötigen wir fünf eier
die habe ich bereits in eigelb und
eiweiß getrennt ins eiweiß gebe ich
direkt eine prise salz dadurch wird die
altersstruktur schneller zerstört und
das lässt sich besser aufschlagen
außerdem benötigen wir noch ein wenig
milch 130 gramm weiche butter 150 gramm
zucker und an trockenen zutaten 90 gramm
mehl 60 gramm speisestärke eine packung
backpulver und 60 km/h cacau
zuallererst wird das eiweiß mit dem
schneebesen der küchenmaschine ein bis
zwei minuten land angeschlagen werk eine
küchenmaschine hat der kann auch ein
handrührgerät benutzen
[Musik]
nachdem das eiweiß schon das doppelte
volumen angenommen hat und auch sehr
cremig ist geben wir die hälfte des
zuckers mit hinein und lassen das ganze
noch weitere drei bis vier minuten lang
aufschlagen
[Musik]
diese baiser masse geben wird dann an
die seite da ich jetzt leider nur eine
schüssel habe habe ich das einmal aus
der schüssel ausgenommen und gebe ihnen
die gleiche schüssel meine weiche butter
mit dem restlichen zucker hinein
[Musik]
an der stelle empfiehlt es sich nicht
mehr mit dem schneebesen
weiterzuarbeiten nimmt dafür am besten
den flach hörer und dann lassen wir das
ganze weiß cremig schlagen
[Musik]
anschließend werden nach und nach kurths
die eigelbe untergerührt rührt ihr am
besten nur so lange bis das eigelb sich
jeweils mit dem restlichen teig
verbunden hat und dann könnte schon das
nächste hinzugeben
das was hier vom rand noch nicht
mitgenommen wurde das nehme ich mit
einem teig darunter und dann ferro ich
das ganze noch mal kurz miteinander
[Musik]
nun kommen die trockenen zutaten mit
hinein und die früher ich vorher gut
miteinander und anschließend siebe ich
sie denn dadurch entstehen keine
klümpchen und der teig wird lockerer
ihr dürft jetzt auf keinen fall den
fehler machen und die trockenen zutaten
in einem schwung mit rein tun macht das
immer nach und nach so habt ihr die
garantie dass euer teig perfekt wird
[Musik]
jetzt werden die zutaten so lange
eingerührt bis sich das ganze mit
einander verbunden habt und anschließend
geht sie ein paar stücke von dem mädchen
ein
[Musik]
so machen wir jetzt weiter bis die milch
und die trockenen zutaten aufgebraucht
sind wichtig ist dass ihr das ganze
immer abwechselnd macht und mit viel
geduld
[Musik]
so ist der teig noch nicht ganz fertig
erzählen wir noch mit ganz viel liebe
und ganz vorsichtig den eischnee
mitunter und dafür benutzt sie am besten
einen teig schaber
[Musik]
am besten macht ihr das auch in zwei
schritten und ganz vorsichtig damit die
luft enthalten bleibt und euer teig
schön locker bleibt den fertigen teig
geben wir dann in einem mit backpapier
ausgelegte springform und meine hatte
einen durchmesser von 26 cm
[Musik]
die oberfläche jetzt noch schön glätten
und dann kommt der teig bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze für 30 minuten in
den backofen
nach dem backen lassen wir den boden
komplett auskühlen und es geht weiter
mit der mascarpone same gesehen hierfür
benötigen wir 500 gramm mascarpone 250
gramm magerquark 600 milliliter kalte
schlagsahne 14 teelöffel sonderfahrt 1
esslöffel vanille extrakt und 80 bis 100
gramm puderzucker je nachdem wie süß ihr
mögt zuallererst wird die kalte
schlagsahne mit sechs teelöffeln seiner
tat steif geschlagen
[Musik]
sobald die sonne dann aufgeschlagen
wurde geben wir sie bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
und machen weiter mit den restlichen
zutaten
in einer separaten schüssel werden
mascarpone quark und wendel extrakt
miteinander verrührt
[Musik]
dann gebe ich acht teelöffel salat mit
hinzu und fahrer das miteinander
[Musik]
man kann direkt erkennen dass die
mascarpone creme auf anhieb fester wurde
hier gebe ich jetzt noch das restliche
seiner fahrt mit hinein und verrührt das
gut miteinander und hier seht ihr die
masse ist schon ziemlich fest und das
ist auch gut so dann haben wir später
einen richtig schönen schnitt jetzt süße
ich das ganze noch mit puderzucker
ich habe 400 gramm genommen ihr könnt da
variieren 80 gramm 120 gramm ist
eigentlich völlig egal je nachdem wie
süß ihr mögt ich mag es immer ein
bisschen süße zu guter letzt themen wir
jetzt noch die sahne unter die war bis
jetzt im kühlschrank die solltet ihr
auch im kühlschrank lagern und nicht auf
zimmertemperatur und jetzt nehme ich das
mit meinem tisch aber schön vorsichtig
unter
[Musik]
hier arbeite ich wieder in mehreren
schritten und gebt nicht gleich die
ganze sache mit hinzu so könnte sie viel
besser unterheben
[Musik]
unsere kämen ist jetzt fertig und es
geht weiter mit der zusammenstellung der
torte
mein tortenboden habe ich in der mitte
durch geteilt und gebe einen boden jetzt
auf eine tortenplatte darum lege ich
dann meinen tortenring und gebe die
erste hälfte der sahne creme auf dem
boden
ich habe die sahne creme tatsächlich mit
der küchenwaage abgewogen und hp exakt
die hälfte drauf getan ihr müsst es
natürlich nicht so genau machen aber
dann habt ihr die garantie dass der
anschnitt auch wirklich schön aussieht
nachdem die erste creme schicht schön
bleibt verstrichen wurde gebe ich die
torte ganz kurz an die seite und zeigt
euch die zutaten für die schoko schicht
hierfür benötigen wir 100 gramm
geschmolzene vollmilch ouvertüre 60
gramm creme fraiche oder schmand und 30
gramm geschmolzene butter
jetzt werden ganz einfach alle drei
zutaten miteinander verrührt ich gebe
hier zuallererst die butter mit in die
förmlich kuvertüre anschließend geben
wir noch creme fraiche mit hinzu und das
ganze wird zu einer homogenen masse
verrührt
jetzt wird die schokocreme auf die torte
verteilt
nachdem die schoko schicht dann glatt
verstrichen wurde geben wir sie zum
aushärten 15 minuten lang in den
kühlschrank
anschließend wird die zweite seine maske
komisch ich drauf verteilt und noch mal
glatt gestrichen
[Musik]
jetzt lassen wir die torte noch mal ein
bis zwei stunden lang komplett durch
kühlen damit wir sie anschließend mit
der glasur überziehen können
für die schokoglasur benötigen wir 300
gramm geschmolzene vollmilchpulver türe
und 250 gramm geschmolzene butter die
zwei zutaten werden jetzt gut
miteinander verrührt und dann ist die
völlig klar so auch schon fertig
auf die gut durch gekühlte torte gebe
ich jetzt mein zweiter tortenboden den
könnt ihr natürlich auch schon vorher
auf die torte geben so habe ich
allerdings ein viel besseres gefühl ob
die torte wirklich komplett durch
gekühlt und ausgehärtet ist
nun löse ich den rand der torte mit
einer flachen winkel palette und hebe
den tortenring nachdem wir den
tortenring entfernt habt könnt ihr noch
backpapier streifen um die torte herum
legen damit auch keine förmlich
kuvertüre diese wir platte verschmutzt
war hinterher gar nicht wirklich nötig
aber sicher ist sicher
und deswegen habe ich diesen schritt
nicht ausgespart
die voll mit glasur verstreicht die
jetzt auf den kompletten kuchen ich
mache das am liebsten so dass ich erst
die oberfläche glatt streichen und dann
die seiten
vor die glasur jetzt allerdings
aushärtet nehme ich noch mein torten
einteiler und teile die torte in 14
gleich große stücke
auf jedes tortenstück gebe ich jetzt die
hälfte meiner schräg angeschnitten
kinder pinguins und die restlichen regel
verteile ich dann in der mitte
sobald die glasur dann schön fest ist
ist eure kinder pinguine torte auch
schon fertig und servier bereit
[Musik]
ich habe die torte für einen geburtstag
gebacken und ich bin mir sicher ihr
findet auch einen tollen anlass diese
leckere torte nach zu backen
falls euch das video gefallen hat dann
freue ich mich natürlich sehr über euer
abo und über einen daumen nach oben bis
zum nächsten mal tschüss
[Musik]